there's two approaches that that you can
take in a situation like this you can
put blinders on and or rose-colored
glasses and or rose-colored blinders
and you can ignore what's happening and
you can try to will
right will it to a good result or
or you can deal with reality and
in that distinction is basically
the attitude or the sharp differences in
attitude
that have shaped our national reaction
to the virus
because there have been too many people
who have just been rooting for a
positive outcome
presuming a positive outcome don't don't
bring me down
man with negativity don't tell me about
how this virus is killing people
even though it is uh and and
because of that we've got this stew this
toxic stew of stupidity and selfishness
that has caused people
to not wear masks to not take it
seriously and here we are
where football season is in jeopardy
we're football season
outside of a full league-wide bubble may
not work
because we collectively failed to take
it seriously
but those of us who have been trying
from day one
to get everyone to take it seriously not
not
simply to save football season although
that would be nice but
to keep as many people in the country
alive as possible and to keep the virus
from
sickening people you know all that
matters is the mortality rate tell that
to somebody who was on a ventilator for
seven weeks before they got a chance to
go home
i have a feeling for them it's about
more than the mortality rate or the
people who are worried about whatever
long-term health conditions they may
have
and nobody knows at this point because
we don't know anything about the virus
yet yeah six months in what the hell do
we know about it
other than it's killed 150 000 people
and it's sickened more and all but but
oh 90 percent of the people are 95
whatever it's numbers it's statistics
it's selective use of data
it's all aimed for whatever reason and
getting people to not take it seriously
and because we haven't taken it
seriously chris
here's where we are and the idea
that you me peter king anyone else
because we dare to point out reality or
somehow rooting against football season
is offensive
it's over the top and at
it yeah i'm stopping there i'm stopping
there
i probably already have gone too far
chris here's an example of why we should
take it seriously thank you matt casey
for steering me in the right direction
eric sugarman the head athletic trainer
of the minnesota vikings and
their designated infection control
officer with whom peter king met
within the past week or two right he's
tested positive
for covet 19. the guy who's in charge of
the vikings
system for making sure that no one gets
it has got it
which doesn't mean that he's been
reckless or careless it just shows you
how insidious this thing is and then
the miami marlins had to shut down why
because they got 14 people who tested
positive
and the phillies had to not play on
monday night because they played the
marlins on sunday and we're waiting to
see whether to what extent the virus got
transmitted among them chris
here's the thing baseball ain't like
football
and if this even begins to happen in
football
and we find out a day after there's been
11 on 11 football for three hours
that 14 guys from one team are positive
probably a greater chance that guys from
the other team are going to end up
positive too
well yeah all right so dude and that's
not negative that's reality
that is reality you're right well i mean
i think the first thing
that you know our first example is
reality i mean there you go
i mean you know we got a we got a head
athletic trainer for the minnesota
vikings
who we know from peter king and from
other people
and his in his own statement that he is
taking this virus very seriously
i'm sure he's going home and being very
serious about it as well i mean he's in
his job
depends on it a lot of people the amount
of income he gets this year
i'm sure is dependent on how many games
we play is it a full season
and of course he takes his job seriously
and knows he needs to be clean because
he's got to be around a lot of other
people
who you know may be clean or mostly
clean but may not and
he's trying to set the right example
there and it just shows you there's a
guy that's smart
and doing the right things and bam he's
got it so you know there's no dodging
this thing
and then with baseball okay that's a you
know yes
disaster i mean you know i want to go
back to what i said yesterday no
shocker the team in miami's got an
outbreak
i would have never thought that i don't
think i could have connected those dots
but there was also a trail of stupidity
that led up to this
too you know them having uh you know
information that it was already starting
on their team
and you know they could have maybe cut
the cord here
a little earlier and stopped it but
regardless this is where we are
and now yeah they're gonna have to make
up games and we go from there
yeah they let they let noted
epidemiologists
masquerading as a shortstop make the
decision as to whether or not they were
going to play on sunday
are you kidding me are you kidding me
that's right i mean they knew they had
they knew the virus was in the locker
room i believe they knew it on the plane
ride
up there if i'm not if i'm not corr uh
you know
if correct me if i'm wrong i believe but
so yeah that shows a checklist and
things of
you know first off i think if we just
compare it to football i don't think
football is going to make those type of
mistakes
they're not going to like you know the
new england patriots aren't going to be
like
hey guys we got coveted 19. devin
mccourty
what do you think we should do as an
organization should we play or not
okay yeah i mean that that was just
ridiculous so
uh i'm hoping that football is smarter
than baseball
along those lines even though i know
this is not going to be easy and i'm
certainly not taking anything for
granted
well and and that's really the point
chris i don't think football would let
it come to something like this
of course if we'd have been talking
about this yesterday this specific topic
i'd have said
surely baseball wouldn't do something so
asinine right
to allow a player to decide whether or
not to go forward
after you've got clear evidence of an
outbreak but but here's
what it tells me it tells me that in
this
atmosphere that we're now in there's
always going to be
a doughnut hole that you can fall into
there's always going to be
something it's going to be the thing
that you didn't think about that's going
to reach up and grab you
when you least expect it because this
thing is so
is so potent from the standpoint of how
it spreads i mean when the guy who is
the chief employee responsible for
keeping it out of the vikings facility
can't keep it out of his own body
it tells you that the virus sets
the agenda the virus determines
the timeline and the virus no one else
is going to decide whether or not
football can be played this year no
matter what steps
are taken by the nfl in large part
because
we didn't take it seriously enough
because the same sentiment that was
communicated yesterday by kyle brandt
is the attitude that so many had back in
march and april
live your life it's no big deal don't
hide under your bed
don't shut down liberate michigan do
this
do that let everyone out again and
here's where we are we're making
progress in may
then everything opens up again and
here's where we are that's why
football's in jeopardy
and i'm making no apologies for pointing
out reality
and the point is we better figure out
what the hell we're going to do or
football season won't happen i mean i
want to be one of the ones with a shovel
right i want to be one of the ones
trying to help the nfl come up with a
solution let's sit back and say oh it'll
be fine
we'll be fine this is you know the meme
of the guy the
the whatever the animal is drinking
coffee in the burning room saying this
is fine
that's what so many people are right now
the room's on fire
folks and we need to try to put it out
before it engulfs
the sport of football period and you
know i chris the point i raised
yesterday and i'm curious about your
thoughts on this
is it two thanks it's a dog i didn't
know what it was it's a dog thank you
pete demelitis for letting me know that
it's a dog in that meme i never really
bothered to stop it's some kind of
cartoon character
anyway can the nfl pull off a bubble
could the nfl right now
right now say man look at baseball yeah
okay and even if you have to delay the
start of the season until october
november yep can they find a location
where they can take everybody
and build the practice fields that would
become game fields
build dormitories or find vacant
buildings they can convert to dormant
it's probably a herculean task at this
point it is but i feel like they're
gonna wish they should
should have done it by the time it's all
said and done well i mean you know
i mean you know our our guinea pigs are
of course baseball
and then we look at basketball right and
they seem to have things certainly under
control now
you know i know they haven't started
playing games and things like that yet
but
we'll see where that goes now bubble for
the nfl you know we discussed this a
little last week i can't remember if we
did it during the show or pftot
you know maybe maybe you could have
pulled it off
if you decided back in late march early
april
okay whoa i don't like the way things
are going we need to figure this out
but i mean to what you just said mike i
think it's too late in the game
i do you know again this is this is
different than basketball where there's
you know 10 12 guys on a team and just a
handful of coaches
you know it's it's not only all the all
the practice fields that you'd have to
worry about and the juggling of all the
players
and of course that you had the meeting
rooms is there enough of that
meetings are so important in football
little areas to do walk-throughs
you know so could they have maybe pulled
off a
you know let's say uh an eight or
four bubbles where it's like the afc
east and the nfc easter all in this
bubble somewhere and
you know the nfc north and afc north
yeah
maybe but it it's that time's gone now
we got 32 individual bubbles and i just
don't even think it's possible to think
about that anymore or
do we just have to say okay fine we'll
do it but we're not going to start
football in november november
and that's my question at this point is
there a way if they start now
if they say you know what we're going to
apply foresight here we're going to be
proactive
we're not going to just say let's see
what happens
like baseball did we are going to go
back to square one
we're gonna dust off the bubble plans
and i'd like to think
or at least hope that back in march
someone was told at the league
office to put together a bubble plan to
start making a list of all the things
that need to be done to brainstorm all
the different ways that it would need to
happen and all the potential locations
if you had to do it and again it
probably is too much
for the nfl to have pulled off i'd love
to know if they would have
truly thought about it back in march
because here's the thing back in march
it i i don't i you know i i want to say
on one hand we really couldn't have seen
this coming
on the other hand i kind of remember
talking to my wife about this when it
all first started and saying
you know here's what's going to happen
we're going to shut down for a while
and then there's going to be a rebellion
against that and people are just going
to go live their lives again
and that's when it's going to take off
that that we contain it for a little
while but people aren't going to be able
to stay locked up
long enough to just let this thing you
know get under control
and at some point we're going to be back
the way we were and it's going to wash
through the country and it's going to be
everywhere
and here we are and that's what we're
dealing with and we're seeing those
effects
on baseball because they're not in a
league wide bubble chris hockey's in a
bubble
in canada they got several positive
tests right zero right
zero they're in a bubble and they're tan
country is the key word
well exactly yeah they're in a country
that's you know they're they're killing
it as far as the virus
and you know as far as where the state
of their country is at
but you're right mike i mean that's
where we are as a country and
uh it's it's it's hurting everything
you know and it's again where i just
argue with people at times to just
you know and and i'll say this i'm still
very happy with what i
see up here like in the new york
connecticut area
you know mike i went to a restaurant on
on saturday night
16th wedding anniversary first time
we've done it since the pandemic started
you know congratulations thank you but
it was great i mean it was good to get
out in society my point is
you can get out and we can start society
if people will just do the
things that are that are set forth to be
done
to start getting back to some normalcy
and wearing the mask as you enter the
restaurant
you know the restaurant all the tables
were about eight feet apart
if not more than that probably about ten
all right
so those freedoms are there to be had
sports can be there to be had but we
gotta get behind it as a country and
that's where it's frustrating right now
and right now we have yeah like you said
people who are just going
will be okay or you know it won't happen
to me
and that's dragging everything down and
uh it's gonna ruin a lot of people's
lives or certainly make a lot of our
lives a lot harder
well and it threatens football season
and again we can sit back and say oh
we're being positive and we're gonna
we're gonna scour the news and we're
only gonna bring you the positive no
negative vibes here baby
and then we and then we're gonna be
wondering in november where the hell
football is
who took our football away because we
were so focused on being positive
that we weren't trying to number one get
people to do the things they need to do
in their local communities to limit the
spread of the virus for their own good
for their families good and for the good
of football and
number two because we were ignoring it
we're shocked
when something we really want isn't
there i i need you
bad it's driving me crazy mike i can't
watch netflix and hulu anymore i'm just
sick of it i really am
all of them i just want to watch some
live tv i was so pissed at the marlins
yesterday for messing up my monday night
i wanted to watch the yankees in the
phillies
and it's it's i just i i'm craving it
right now sorry i didn't mean to
interrupt you but it just it speaks to
where i am as a sports man right now in
this time
yeah because the the the the whole
reason we're talking about this is
because chris wasn't able to watch the
angle
yeah pissing me off it's ruining my life
because people are endangered by the
spread of the virus
you know you mentioned the possibility
of multiple bubbles that's intriguing to
me dr alan seals the nfl's chief medical
officer said
yesterday to espn that they've
essentially created 32 virtual football
bubbles
but here's the problem once those
bubbles start to intermingle
if you have bubbles in places like
houston and dallas
which you will miami which you will
phoenix
la the places where the virus is
currently out of control
when those bubbles start intermingling
with bubbles from places where the virus
isn't out of control that's when you
start spreading it and that's when they
need to be concerned
what you know and i i've got all sorts
of ideas and i just hope that people
smarter than me that bar is low
who work for the nfl are brainstorming
on these things and wondering would it
make sense would it make sense could it
make sense at this point
to move some of that now you know you're
talking about uprooting guys lives for
four months that's the problem
families right but but you know do you
move teams out of miami for the year i
mean if fans aren't going to be there
anyway who cares if you're playing
at hard rock stadium or somewhere else i
it's
these are all things that should have
been dealt with back in march because
that's the problem you can't change this
specific
tire on a moving car this car is moving
too damn fast
and there's too many lug nuts on the
tire to try to change it while the car
is moving
they're at the point where they have
they have picked their path
and they have got to live with it yeah
and hope for the best right
and there's going to be a lot of rolling
of the dice chris that's right see if it
works out and to say that
does not mean we're being negative we're
being realistic there is an element of a
gamble
every step of the way this year training
camp
when the games start it's going to be a
day in and day out
week in and week out thing and we're
going to feel good one day
and we're going to feel bad the next day
and we're going to worry one day is it
going to work
and then the next day we're going to
think maybe it will work and then a game
is going to get postponed
yeah and then another game is going to
get played and this is just our reality
chris
until they they hoist the super bowl
trophy which i am convinced they
eventually will
even if they only play two weeks of a
regular season there's going to be a
super bowl trophy at the end of the day
yeah well i i hope so i mean but yeah
mike i mean
we got to adjust on the fly as we go
here i mean that's where we're at
we're in too deep you know we've gone
past the point of the nfl like dipping
their toe into the water with
this whole scenario we're already you
know waist deep in this and
they've got you know some very strong
protocols put in place
but you're you're right i think the big
thing is i mean
yeah it's 32 bubbles but is it really a
bubble
i mean no it's not a bubble because it's
a bubble with
i mean a whole lot of holes in it that's
what i'll say it's not like the nba
as we know they're all staying there in
disney world and they're not leaving
that so
yes are there some tentacles off of that
sure
you know i'm sure some of the employees
of course that are working at disney are
going home at night i know that disney's
probably doing the right thing
to make sure they're not coming back
infected or whatever like that
but in the nfl hey yeah cool 32 bubbles
right right but then a guy goes home and
you know he's got three kids at home and
one kid was at a camp with five kids
over here today
and another kid was you know down the
street with jimmy and then
you know the wife had to go to the store
so
now we have three different tentacles of
all right how many people were you guys
around and how far did that
those tentacles go and that's where it's
just like you've said it it's undefeated
right now it's
that's where i don't know how you
actually can stop that and
uh it's not a real bubble it's it's it's
a make-believe bubble with a
you know we're hoping that you know
cinderella's magic uh shoe fits
every night and everyone comes back
clean every day and we're like oh i hope
it works
so we'll see and we won't find out until
the next day that's the problem
so there's until there is point of care
testing with a rapid response
where you can clear a guy before he gets
into the facility every day
you are 24 hours behind what that guy's
status says you know we said yesterday
maybe when it's time to set rosters
there will be a preference for the guys
who are stable and who have families
versus the guys who are single and maybe
inclined to
to go give in to the temptations to go
out and about maybe end up with the
virus
i don't know chris if i feel like i can
properly keep the single guy
from doing things he shouldn't do then i
don't have to worry about
the kids bringing it home if if they're
in school or if they're going to a
friend's house
and and the the dad who's on the nfl
team getting the virus that way so
you're right there's a lot of different
ways
that this virus can permeate a facility
a football field
and create the kind of problems that
we're seeing for the miami marlins the
commissioner sent a letter yesterday
to fans and i i
look of course there's hope and there's
optimism that's the message they need to
send
but i noticed him use a word for the
second time in three days
and i think this underscores the reality
of the 2020 season
he said we are committed to playing a
healthy and
complete season they used to say full
season
now they say complete season they played
a complete season in 1982 chris when
they were nine regular season games
right
they played a complete season in 1987
when there were 15 regular season games
three of which were
populated by replacement players so
complete means
here's the trophy we're not making any
statement or promise as to how many
games are going to be played
before we hand out the trophy so i agree
and i believe
it will be a complete season i agree and
i believe that when
when it's all said and done there will
be confetti cannons shot
and someone will be holding it up and
they will be the champs and there may or
may not be an asterisk on the season
but it will happen the question is how
many games are we going to see
before we get to the point there's 269
total games now
yeah with regular season and postseason
how many of those 269 are actually what
what
what's your over under like not not like
let's just say let's just go into a
regular season like
we got you know we got what 17 games now
256.
no 200 no next year 60. sorry 16 games
now but like
what look average per team what are you
saying right now like what how many do
you think we get to you think we're
going to get to i have no idea
i i i have no idea i'd like to let's
say let's say nine and a half is the
over underpinning okay
yeah i mean baseball made me feel like
we're gonna have a week one game now
like in the nfl we'll probably get there
and then we're gonna have to like take
two weeks off
and then we're gonna have a you know a
season again for a week or two and we're
gonna have to take another week off
i mean that's just the way i have a
feeling or at least this is what's
entered my brain after this weekend with
some of the things we've seen to where
yeah it might just be choppy the year we
might get one two weeks in a row right
great but great and then it disappears
for two weeks
and then everybody gets healthy and we
play a few more games and then it comes
out again and
i don't know maybe that's the way it
goes this year and we just got to get
ready for that
yeah and i think they're going to be
determined to play as many games as they
possibly can but they are going to be
safe there aren't going to be position
players making decisions on whether or
not games go forward the nfl is going to
be actively involved i have to give them
credit there
but the reality is the approach with 32
football bubbles that aren't really
bubbles
this facility is a bubble but the
individuals aren't
living there right they're not sleeping
on the floor there they go home like you
said
they could bring that virus back and
until we have point of care testing
there's no way to know
on a given day that a guy is or isn't
shedding virus until
the next day and if that happens on a
sunday when a game is played
that's when uh you have to worry that
the outbreak
has started and then maybe you do have
to shut it down for a week or at least
postpone individual games that's
something that peter king has
hinted at in his latest football morning
in america column all right let's take a
break
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports